[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was my favorite thing
to do with thanksgiving leftovers is amy
poehler wrote give them to a homeless
person
jim parsons wrote make turkey sandwiches
chris christie wrote thanksgiving what
overs
i usually wake up around
tina fey wrote 6 a.m
brooklyn decker wrote 7 a.m
lindsay lohan wrote screaming policemen
people stand
[Music]
you don't think she understood that i
think she had a little problem
understanding okay uh
i'll talk to you after the show people
people always ask what are you doing
here when i'm in a brad pitt wrote
walmart
george clooney wrote mcdonald's
stephen tyler wrote men's room
[Applause]
the most
the most important part of a successful
restaurant is gordon ramsay wrote
getting only the freshest ingredients
anthony bourdain wrote hiring the most
skilled chefs
guy fieri wrote putting sunglasses on
all the cheeseburgers
my favorite christmas carol is snoop
dogg wrote the little drummer boy
l.l cool j wrote jingle bells
kanye west wrote the 12 kanye's of kanye
that's a good
good one yeah
seven kanye's leaping my favorite
shampoo
is julianne moore wrote aveda
steve martin wrote oxyton
donald trump wrote shameless possum
[Laughter]
my parents got so angry the day i came
home with christina aguilera wrote
tattoos
nicole richie wrote piercings
larry king wrote opposable thumbs
and finally sometimes it's scary to
think al gore wrote what might become of
our planet don cheadle wrote what might
happen if the economy doesn't turn
around elmo wrote who's had their hand
inside me for the past 10 years
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]